one more drink one more
drink you know in the morning
for sure we gonna stink one more
round one more round
it's
this is what we do catch up for a few
we'll riff and talk some [ __ ] and then
we'll sleep till two
[Music]
you look like a little ski bunny out
there
i had to turn the heat off in order to
to not
interfere with the audio here so i'm
yeah i feel like a ski bunny
yeah you look cute i like the puffer is
that is that a new york bar you got
there
that's a it's a subway in is behind me
it's an old new york classic it's a real
dive
many stories there as a as a youngin
well it was originally on originally on
59th
and lex subway stop but
uh it's now i think it's on like york or
something it's a movie oh wow
we had a lot of weird nights in here and
yes
well that when you go that far east in
manhattan it gets
chicken's dark you know like the street
lights aren't on and
the river's right there i used to make
love to a woman who lived on york
and it felt like another another burrow
it's so different over there
it's uh it was cool because yeah we'd
get weird stories
there were weird nights remember one
time the bartender just grabbed
a friend of mine and just stuck his
tongue down his throat
and it and it wasn't even like a sexual
thing it was like i own you
whoa it was that type of vibe we were
like holy [ __ ] all right
yes he worked there and he was a
customer and he was like i don't give a
[ __ ] about you
wait it was a lady no he's a two men
what oh wow yes damn that's crazy
i own you i don't know that's a that's a
new one for me it was a power move they
would do there was like a lot of power
[ __ ] like we'd be hammered and they'd be
like you
you like and they'd be like all right
free shot i'm like oh i'll do whiskey's
like you don't get to choose
he would just like dump tequila put in
hot sauce and he'd be like take it you
[ __ ] and be like all right
all right it's a free drink i'll take it
for sure
yeah i was gonna say i thought it was a
lady and i remember
when i was 18 19 20 there was a lot of
cougary milfied ladies who were so
sexually aggressive that nobody talks
about like
they would be like grab my tit you [ __ ]
and you're like okay okay
i guess because they were so repressed
with their with their limp husband or
whatever that they would always
you know like grab your ass or grab your
dick or there's nothing here
[ __ ] and you're like i'm sorry mrs
susie
you ever have those or was that a dwarf
no okay like this
smoking you know raspy voice bad skin on
the neck
you thought either aggressive older
woman was strictly like a creole
like southern you think you thought it
was a voodoo queen
it's like it's like uh it's like new
orleans law it's only it's only applies
in [ __ ] louisiana
yeah i get but man yeah there was a lot
and i dug it i wasn't it i wasn't
against it but
it was [ __ ] hard it was a thing yeah
just old old birds uh with like a
leather jacket on
and bad jeans with like rhinestones on
the back you know
kind of trashy i used to have an old bit
about a woman in a bar she goes
i could be your mother and i was like
i'm pretty sure you're not
you know yeah my mom doesn't get
hammered and dives on tuesdays
so right safe right yeah
so true i mean if i saw my mom playing
video poker at
at one of these new orleans dive bars
i'd kill myself
that's the saddest thing she's got her
own chair that's my stool
[ __ ] you know the quarters and the
cigarette pack the american spirits next
to the gin and tonic
video poker is a perfect that's like a
line and so it's got to be like a punch
line there because it's so it's so
perfect it's such a [ __ ] hilarious
image yes yes like what's the other one
top golf or whatever
top flight or whatever top golf or uh i
mean big bug hunter was the ultimate
that's
that's a fun one though that's a good
that one's actually not sad
yeah that's kind of cool top golf was
cool too but there was always the guy
who was too good at it you know and
you're like you got to get outside
go play a game of golf you need some
sunlight just that
it was too much how about uh were you
ever into like the drinking bar games
like would you get into beer pong or
like flip cup or any of that [ __ ]
yeah i mean i lived in a house with five
guys in college so it was like
we had a pool room so it was just pool
table then we turned into a beer pong
table a ping pong table we'd play poker
every monday
uh we'd play like guts and kings and all
these drinking games it was
it was a while it's funny tom tom
mccaffrey has that great joke about like
alcohol is the only drug you play games
with no one yeah no one's ever like
crack pong
yeah it's true
it's something about those games where
like i do
i do kind of miss them because they make
you feel young again but then you're
like oh yeah i don't play this [ __ ] at
this age for a reason
you're drinking so much beer when you do
that [ __ ] oh
it's so much do you ever do it without
with hard alcohol
i've done it before it's it's a puke
fest it's always a mistake
you don't think it's that much like oh
it's just like a tiny thing but then
you're like did i just drink
six shots like that you know exactly
crazy
do you this is this is next level
dirtbag [ __ ] but do you remember power
hour
how did that go again every minute for
an
hour you take a shot of beer which
you're like oh i can do this
and then after like 17 minutes you're
like ah the minutes are flying by and
just shooting beer you end up drinking
like 12 beers
in an hour i was never yeah i was more
like a game guy like flip cup but i
wasn't really a power hour or we do like
if we were watching a show or something
we turned into a game like every time he
says this you got to do a shot or
whatever but i was right
now it's bad news by the way you
mentioned
games drinking games with that people do
that with this show somebody told me
every time i do this they
drink and every time you say you said
something like baby
that's it baby they drink
so that that was kind of flattering
that's awesome i love that i love this
and you know and then i saw
we had a lot of tweets and stuff people
mentioning that like they're sober and
they still love the show
and that like like they appreciated us
shouting out sober people because that
that is hard especially
this year man holy [ __ ] yeah i mean we
couldn't do we're not that strong
no god that is you're right it's a
strong thing it really
yeah i'll even try like i'm not gonna
drink this week and then your friend's
like oh you want a beer in the fridge
you're like
all right like it's that it's that easy
to turn me
it's so it's such a funny thing where
like i remember old movies like casa
blanc i'd watch growing up and be like
bogart that's a man
you know internalizing his feelings and
drinking himself to death in morocco
that's a real dude you know
so true yeah it was romantic it was
romantic but then you get older and
dealing with [ __ ] is actually
more manly it's more difficult great
point great point i mean like don draper
and ernest hemingway
you know the rocks and the the whiskey
it just looked so
it almost looked classy and yet it's
actually
[ __ ] a sad uh what do you call that
uh
uh vice yeah hemingway was a man though
i mean he wrote like a man he was in the
war
he uh he was such a manly dude i mean
holy [ __ ]
and he killed himself it is kind of a
manly way to go
yeah with a rifle by the way damn pretty
crazy
that was one of my first jokes ever i
said my english teacher said i was going
to be like a young hemingway and i was
like why because i'm a great writer she
goes no you're an alcoholic who's going
to kill himself
that was one of my first that's a that's
a great dark
joke uh david angela had that funny joke
he's like you know uh
ernest hemingway actually wrote in a
moleskin he used moleskin
you know and he's like i believe it
because every time i pay for one i see
the price i want to kill myself
he had some great ones david angel is
hilarious he lives by me we
took a walk the other day he's a fun
dude oh nice talk about
just a comedy character great writer
weird guy funny voice the whole thing
man he's got a joke i love he goes i
went to uh private school and kids are
always beating me up for my brunch money
[Laughter]
he had another one i love he goes uh
yeah when i was a kid we were broke we
uh we had a black and white scent
so every time the incredible hulk got
angry i just thought he turned into an
italian
because you know bruce banner to lou
ferrigno that's a
dude that's an older older reference but
he's perfect joke
he's so funny and then to say italian
not a
italian it's so much funnier yeah my
cousin saw him at a show at ucb and he's
like he's like do you know this guy he's
so funny and i was like oh yeah
he's like very like up his alley kind of
like weird but very clever
yeah he's he's great great joke writer
yeah great he wrote for fallon for like
10 minutes i don't know the daily show
now
and okay great he's like the one like
kind of fringe conservative in the daily
show room keeping them
semi-sane i guess and probably driving
him driving him nuts i'm sure oh
dude he's an angry i mean i just twitter
alone i'm like
i hope this guy's okay his twitter's
great
i know i love you if you want a great
follow
i i think he's hilarious on twitter so
funny so
i like watching people lose it on
twitter it's fun when they like get
honest
it is fun but they're always a people
you're like [ __ ] don't lose it too much
i wouldn't
have a career that's true that's true
because it's real easy to pull a
roseanne
pop an ambien have a red wine and and
say a
black joke or whatever it is have you
ever done a sleeping pill and then done
morning radio the next morning and you
say [ __ ] where you're like oh i [ __ ]
up
oh i've definitely been hungover but i
take sleeping pills every night so
every night you take a sleeping pill
it's a pro i gotta i gotta
i gotta come back to life yeah i just i
need to get sleep i can't
to me it's the falling asleep once i'm
asleep i'm good i just can't turn it off
damn what
what kind of sleeping pill do you take
well i went with the melatonin then
before you know what it was
that's not a pill though that's well
this is just the beginning i was taking
four
then you take five and you're like well
this is done then you start taking a
cbd oil like oh this is helping then
that's not doing anymore so then
i do a tylenol pm but then you're like i
don't need the tylenol so am i
hurting my liver and uh after a while it
was just i would do ambien
damn every night i kicked ambien
every night because i was falling asleep
like sitting up
places it was it was really embarrassing
i was pulling like a grandpa
i the problem with me with melatonin is
i already have nightmares and it for
some reason makes my nightmare so vivid
interesting do you know that's the thing
that's why people do weed
i think is because it actually will help
i think i don't know which one is it
into
the indica the one that helps you sleep
i think that one helps with nightmares
they say
oh that's [ __ ] fat boy they've really
these scientists man they really
mastered the weed it comes i know it's a
hacky joke now but it's like so
impressive these strains this one makes
you hungry that's what makes you sleepy
that's what makes you
less anxious yeah they have i mean it's
like it's crazy where it's coming our
lifestyle a lifetime i mean i remember
like getting into a car
to like get you know get weed from a
stranger and like yeah that's [ __ ]
weird as a kid to do and now it's like
you know soda's got that bit like how
they're like is it's crazy
yeah they are that's such a great point
and and the funny thing is these guys
are in a lab coat they're scientists
they're botanists
but they still keep the names funny
which i love you know it's like
you want to get uh maui wowie or anal
fisher or do you want uh the squirter or
do you want uh
you know whatever the hell bobby flay
there's always some fun name they they
could have fisher they could have held
off on the names but they hung in there
anal fisher i think she was on boy meets
world
tobanga oh she was hot
she was hot oh yeah i looked her up not
too long ago
did you oh these kids today have no idea
what they got with the internet they can
see any
child star nude they got an only fans
they got google i mean
back in our day if she did playboy once
you were lucky
terry hatcher is doing playboy you know
did she
oh yeah jenny mccarthy and nicole smith
you know
jenny mccarthy man i remember that was
like that was a good time to be a hot
chick because they were like yeah we'll
give you a comedy show like that's how
low the [ __ ] bar was
yeah all you do is pretend to fart or
like you know
squeeze a tit and you were a comedian if
you were a hot chick
yeah she wasn't funny no tv really was
throwing [ __ ] at the wall
they really were like jenny mccoy
occasionally they they'd land back in
the day right
even like singled out back in the day
you're like oh [ __ ] that was kind of
crazy yeah yeah chris young chris
hardwick right
right and uh carmen electra talking
about the 90s
so hot we sound like real boomers right
now
i guess i i think we're technically
millennials but
i don't feel like a millennial yeah i
don't either
yeah like weird my friend has he's got
this great joke he's like man i used to
make fun of millennials and i gave it a
google search
and he's like i stopped making fun of
him because he is one and it's so true
like millennial is
80 on i think ooh so we're definitely in
there
what's the one after that gen z
and when does that start 90 really
i think so 95 i i could be wrong
call in if you know what are you
drinking by the way oh
good question well as you know don't
don't buy the background i'm in a
hilton garden inn in omaha nebraska
not bragging and uh so i realized i went
to the club i did a show and i came back
and i said i got to do a pod
but i forgot to bring a cocktail so i
went down a little
little mark they got down the little
market in the lobby
all they got was a lemon truly
oh man so i'm gonna be that guy
a lemon truly i'm like a hot chick at a
like a
kentucky derby over here that sounds
like a homophobic dad calls his gay son
you [ __ ] lemon truly that's what
hemingway would call me
there it is folks i love the background
i love it i got a little i got a
manhattan going i'm unoriginal went back
i was going to do a ball vda or whatever
they're called it's when they do
sweet vermouth uh bourbon
and campari but it was kind of like ah
i'd rather do they have another one i'll
do it another week called an old pal
which i like better it's
it's dry vermouth uh bourbon and campari
it's [ __ ] good
can we just go on a limb and say that
might be your favorite cocktail
yeah i like a manhattan it's like it's a
it's a cocktail it's strong
it's got a little sweetness it's got a
little a little tart i love i love it
it's perfect perfect cocktail
it is great it's not too much of
anything it's not too tart not too sweet
not too strong but it's
it's got a ball it's got all the flavors
gives you a nice buzz too
like it makes you just feel it's like
it's a good drunk for me i've been doing
i've been doing wine a decent amount
like a little red wine in the winter
scotch in the winter
but uh man it's cold out snow in here
man that's why you're stuck in omaha
right
i know i saw the photos or i saw some
news reports from new york
and uh man it is coming down it's like a
white out out there
and i had a flight at 6 a.m it's a
nightmare getting out of omaha and 18
layovers and a bus and a train and a
tram and all this [ __ ]
and uh they just i got a text today it's
a canceled flight
so i had to like reschedule i'm sure
that'll get cancelled so
tomorrow is gonna be a whole airport day
i can already feel it
damn i hate i hate a stressful travel
day man
nothing nightmare nightmare it's it's
brutal i mean
luckily you know i got a phone and wi-fi
so i can get some work done at the
airport but it's just
you just can't relax the whole day then
you finally get home at like midnight
and you gotta uber to your house it's
a nightmare [ __ ] yeah i i don't miss
that i haven't been on the road in a bit
like flying in a bit but i'll be back at
it soon i'm sure
uh yeah yeah i miss it yeah it seems
like it's it's starting to open up a
little
yeah i think it's going to open up a
little i mean it's like people are
getting
the vaccines and stuff i think the
numbers are going to go down i know
january was like the worst month but i
think it's like
it's it's the worst right now it's going
to it's going to go downhill i think
yeah yeah i think so and like my mom has
the vaccine my dad has the vaccine
girlfriend's mom is the fact so like
it's getting around pretty good i think
i know people are bitching about it but
if my mom's got it that's a good sign
what uh any good wrecks oh man this is
going to sound weird
but uh i was flipping through my
cable package if you know what i mean i
don't want to get too into it because i
don't get yelled at
but i was flipping through my [ __ ] there
and i s i'm a big documentary guys you
know
saw a documentary on leonard skinner i
go yeah you know they're a
popular band i've never really gotten
into them but i'll listen sweet home
alabama
amazing doc blew my mind i couldn't
believe it
damn give me some highlights well it's
called if i leave here tomorrow
and it's just so crazy you know we've
all heard the band story these guys meet
up they play in a garage
you know they do drugs then they all
suddenly hit it big but
these are redneck guys from florida i
thought they were from alabama
because of the song they live in a shack
on a river
they're all [ __ ] alcoholics their
dads are
[ __ ] rednecks and and idiots and they
kill alligators
and do lsd and have long hair and they
all fail out of school and they just
kept playing guitar all day long and
drums
one guy was writing a song in and out of
jail they all get shot they're all crazy
and uh they just clicked and then
i can't remember how they got bigger but
like one guy signed them
and then they opened for the who and
then they just blew up
oh [ __ ] but they're so cool because
they're
like redneck hillbillies but they're all
about progress
and if you listen to the songs they're
like pumping in
they got that song uh in sweet home
alabama
birmingham had a governor boo
boo boo apparently he was a big racist
damn
so they're like sliding in all this
subliminal woke [ __ ]
in their hillbilly tunes everybody
thinks it's like bar room drinking
and uh you know there's a there's a bit
in there dude oh
maybe like just modernizing that like
that's so [ __ ] funny
yeah i mean they had the whole song
about how guns are bad and like they've
all been shot
they all have friends who have guns had
a message board
[Music]
that's [ __ ] awesome dude it's good
man it's really good and you you fall in
love with them they're so sweet and i'm
so humble
hbo or netflix or what is it oh that's
good i think it was show time
oh showtime's got good [ __ ] man good job
remember you turned me onto that kobe
dock muse that was pretty [ __ ]
incredible loved it loved it
incredible too oh i didn't know if i saw
that oh it's incredible
um what are you what are you working on
i got a good
uh i got a good wreck i just read this
you know noir is like my escape right
now i've always been my escape but like
i love there's something about
about noir that's like it takes me to a
different world and the you know
the language is so [ __ ] fun and the
dialogue i read this book called
it's a classic i've never read it by
walter mosley called devil in a blue
dress
yeah of course i never read it i was
just i heard it to class i've never read
it either it's [ __ ] great
it's incredible oh really it's like bass
they made a movie about it with denzel
but he was devil in a red dress wasn't
he no doubt in a blue dress
okay denzel plays uh easy rollins who's
the
who's a detective don cheadle was like
his breakout role is like his
tough friend and uh it's great [ __ ]
book man there's so many good lines in
it where you're like
it's basically like a philip marlow type
detective story but you add in
the racial tension of like the late 40s
post-war he's he served in the military
so he's got all this anger
right you know but then some this is a
colorful villains where like there's a
scene
where uh he's working for this shady
white guy
dewitt perfect [ __ ] perfect white guy
name at that time dewitt
is it southern uh yeah it is yeah no
no no no no it's in la but they're like
houston and like louisiana guys so yeah
i see
so it's got like a southern element for
sure and uh
there's a scene where he's like you know
a tough guy served in the war and he
could [ __ ] [ __ ] up he called himself a
killing machine but these
young white kids are [ __ ] with them
and he's like i can't he's like i could
murder all of them
with my bare hands but i can't do [ __ ]
cuz i'm a black man or whatever and
this guy dewitt comes in he goes are you
[ __ ] with my associate and he says to
the kids get on your knees and suck his
dick
that type of show he pulls out a gun
suck his dick and the kids are crying
and and he basically said afterwards he
was like you would have thought that
gave me some calm but like if he's
willing to do that to one of his own
kind what the [ __ ] would he do to me
like good ass lines like that we were
like oh this is and there was a like
[ __ ] like you know missing it's about a
missing woman
devil in the background right and this
guy goes look look how pretty she is he
goes
he goes yeah if you weren't you wouldn't
be looking for like [ __ ] like that
wow so small you know what i love about
noir
is because it's fiction but it's urban
it's all in the city which i love i love
the city [ __ ] like uh
chinatown with knight jack nicholson all
that [ __ ] because
sci-fi i just fan lord of the rings can
blow me
uh you know harry potter can blow me i
hate all that [ __ ] because i can't get
into it
i love the card with good sci-fi though
like if it's like like dude x machina is
brilliant
oh okay well yeah that that i can get up
but they're not on a spaceship they're
in a guy's house in the hills you know
i can still it it's technology but it's
like good sci-fi but
i'm with you like i prefer in i prefer
noir is more my my [ __ ] yeah yeah
good side i mean i like the original
star wars and [ __ ] i love i love that
yeah
yeah that's good that's a hero's story i
get on board with star wars it's so good
but star trek i hate
really yeah it's just it's a klingon
oh what's going on here uh we're stuck
on a spaceship it's so limited
i'm just not that into it i'm sure we'll
be hearing from joe mackey about this
i hear battlestar galactica is like the
best show ever i've never seen it but
people [ __ ]
go nut people i really trust the south
park guys say it's like the greatest
show ever oh
i trust those guys for sure and our
close friend joe mackey
[Applause]
yeah he's an idiot but yeah no i get it
and it's impressive and they have to
create this whole world in their mind
and that's all cool but like
the matrix i'm on board with because
it's somewhat based in reality but
when you got talking trees and lord of
the rings i'm like
that doesn't exist you heard the story
of will smith turn down that role
for wild wild west i did hear that what
an idiot
that's crazy i probably because he got
to sing a song for wild wild west
probably he was so hot with music at
that time that they were like you get a
song and they were like
he probably has to akovsky brothers he's
like can i have a song and they're like
[ __ ] you you don't miss that can you
imagine the matrix as well like
a [ __ ] red pill red pill
right right yeah that's a good point oh
he had a couple of jiggy with it was
another rough one men in black
men in black was kind of fun men and
black is a good movie good movie
and that that was a graphic novel or
something like that was it
yeah dude that movie is funny that movie
is up barry levinson i think yes
yeah and a great movie that was back
when a black guy and a white guy was
still like
whoa they're partners holy [ __ ] like
look at these two
oh my god like rush hour another 48
hours
men in black yeah but like the
difference between men in black in
uh 48 hours is like 47 slurs
that's true you may watch 48 hours and
you're like does nick nolte like can you
cool it for like a minute it's just
crazy i know i heard half of that was
improvised
[Laughter]
joking
but he looks like that guy like when
he's saying the n-word you're like oh he
means it he's got the bad suit
he's blonde old blonde guy you know yeah
that was
48 hour is a great movie though i mean
that was like a movie where you're like
where like the violence felt real like
like that character who was in
who was in trouble the whole movie that
that bad guy was just trying to like
save his girl whatever like that was a
dark
storyline so like that balanced some
funny ass [ __ ]
yeah some some real stuff you know right
it still had some grit on it but it
still had like a light-heartedness too
it was it's really well done
yeah man eddie murphy [ __ ] rules i
said it before i'll say it again i don't
think he should come back i mean he can
do whatever he wants obviously but
as a stand-up it'll never live up no
matter what
so it's it's that's a weird thing like
we've talked about guys like like the
legends who die young
and you're just like immortalized like
it's not just comedy like you go to cuba
and it's like
che guevara's pictures everywhere you
know because he went out in his prime
and then you have [ __ ] you know
fidel castro lives forever right i mean
right yeah they can't
kill that guy you go out at the you go
out at the peak
yep that's who you are forever like bill
hicks is bill hicks
so true i mean he even has a bit about
it like what if you saw hendrix now
doing like an 18t
commercial or selling [ __ ] depends or
something
like how sad would that be and he
epitomizes that with his early day diet
what 33.
yeah well bill hicks i mean like think
of all the all the greats that died
around that age i mean uh
jesus aside you've got like bruce lee
you've got like you mentioned hendrix
you've got [ __ ]
janice joplin like all these legends
cobain's a big one too yeah is that
cause like how he could have changed
maybe
i know i know turning into a dad and all
that
and he becomes like a fox news guy
[Laughter]
yeah he'd have a podcast about you know
how much pearl jam sucks or whatever
oh bill hicks would be he'd be a podcast
he'd be like jay leno did a [ __ ]
doritos commercial he sold his soul then
cut to like a minute later he's like
which reminds me adam and eve is having
a discount sale
[Laughter]
i know that's so weird to think about
because he would definitely have a
podcast and it would be huge
but you still got to do ads yeah well
can i tell you who
gave me a phone call last week oh i'm
excited
you teased us a little off air so yeah
maybe catch everybody up
all right so i was telling mark that uh
that a
comedy legend give me it gave me a call
uh
weird i mean you've had this with
seinfeld you had seinfeld
hit you up and be like i'm a fan you
hung with jerry
yeah yeah highlight of my life you text
with jerry
yep still text every now and then i
don't i don't overdo it but yep
that's [ __ ] amazing it's the whole
thing is bananas just from watching him
in new orleans with my parents and must
see tv to
sitting on a couch with him at the
beacon i mean the whole thing doesn't
make sense but
that's also a guy though that your
parents like get to or they're like why
can't you work with
seinfeld that's like the name they would
say yes exactly
like you tell them you got into the
comedy seller which is like the biggest
accomplish ever and they're like
the who the what it's a seller it's a
basement okay
well how much you get 30 a set oh cool
they don't get it but then you tell them
i met seinfeld and they're like oh okay
we got something here now we're talking
yeah well that's uh that's a big one
uh yeah so i so i'm doing a thing
on friday it's like you did it too i
think it's that comedy central roast
thing you know what i'm talking about
yeah
well we're like you know doing it took
forever to set up in my apartment like
move this bookshelf move that bookshelf
so i'm like moving [ __ ] around i'm doing
it it was fun i ended up having fun
doing it
but okay a lot of movement my reps are
texting me
jay leno's trying to call you
and i'm like i just got i got like a
missed call and i'm like
what whoa oh my guys can we wrap it up i
want to talk to jay leno
oh my god is he a fan did he see your
set or
give me the whole thing so he watched my
special i got this
and uh and he was like i loved your
special i just wanted to tell you i just
i watched with my wife and we like i
talked to him on the phone for a while
he could have been a nicer guy
great guy i mean this is so i i love jay
leno me and liz always talk about leno
because
biggest misconception is that letterman
is cooler than leno leno is the cool one
you think so oh yeah i mean look
letterman had the better tv show
obviously better
uh late night talk show but leno still
does stand up by the way
yeah letterman gave up stand up a long
time ago he mentioned that he said he's
doing zooms he's doing zoom games what
yeah oh my god also
you do letterman he's ice cold he
doesn't talk to you leno comes in your
dressing room he goes how you doing
what's going on what have you been up to
and then like how long you been doing it
where do you get up and all that [ __ ] he
wants to talk to you
and he like gives you notes and he
comments the tags where his letterman
just goes all right see ya get out of
here
yeah my agent told me that he hits up
some comics and he's cool but he's a
cool guy about that
and then uh yeah he could have been nice
on the phone we talked for like i don't
know 15 minutes or so and he was wow
super nice and he was just like i don't
want to take up your time i'm like
i'm like looking around i'm like do you
know what i'm [ __ ] doing right now
yeah
yeah but uh no he said he hit a cool
line where he said uh
i said well you know it's on youtube so
a lot of my a lot of my views are just
word of mouth you know it's not on
on netflix or anything and he was like
well you know uh word of mouth is big
lyndon johnson had a quote where he said
a handshake is worth 250 votes and he
goes
well i'm going to tell you uh tell a lot
of people about your special and
and they'll tell a lot of people so you
know pretty cool very
very very made my day to say the least
you know totally what a mensch
cool guy great comic that is so odd did
he did he quote any bits or did he
say he said one yeah he said
well maybe i'll see you around sometime
he didn't even like no hard plans but
uh weird time to make plans but uh he
said you know
you guys are doing a pod together well
he said uh
he he quoted a bit about how i said i
can't drive and he thought that was
really he's like i laughed out loud at
that like you know
i'm a big car guy i was like oh i know
yeah but uh
but yeah he said i'm a big car guy and
uh
and he said the fact that you can't
drive you really can't drive and he you
know he's he's
he's hip to [ __ ] where he's like where'd
you film that the comedy seller i'm like
i mean that's cool that he just knows
that
you know yeah totally oh what a guy salt
of the earth regular guy
man i read his book when i was a kid i
read bleeding with my chin when i was a
kid i mean i
it definitely a cool cool thing for sure
super cool wow that that's
i said it before i'll say it again so
the great thing about stand-up is the
the lack of pretension you know like
some bar room
guitar guy is never going to meet mick
jagger and you could we could still meet
seinfeld or leno
or whoever super cool chris rock
whatever it is
yeah no it's pretty crazy and uh that's
one that i told my parents my parents
come
my dad my dad it's weird that my dad
calls me he's like what what did he say
yeah yeah like that type of [ __ ] so i
was like oh man that's pretty cool
that's [ __ ] awesome and and that's
hilarious that he missed you missed the
call too
hilarious because i'm [ __ ] like
moving [ __ ] in my apartment well i'm
like is this good
for this half of the shoot yeah yeah
i'm doing that on tuesday i'm not
looking forward to it it's fine it's
fine it's like the setup is excruciating
like i'm
on no sleep and i was a little hungover
and uh and they're like it was like an
hour of like move this book the other
way
so we don't deal with um you know
copyright
yeah all right is it is it all did you
have to prepare or is it all riff
i wrote a few bits for it but i oh okay
it was funny when you
it's funny when you're doing like so for
those who listen don't know we're
talking about if we weren't clear enough
it's basically like
the top 100 roast jokes ever and they
had comics like me
mark roy wood uh yamaneika people like
us
like just riffing on the jokes so it's
funny when i have a bit where i'm like
that's a good line that i wrote in prep
and then they'd be like
so how did this roast joke make you feel
and i'm like you want me to like
be like here's why this is a good joke
yeah yeah
i want to be like i want to make bits
i'm here to be anyone can dissect a bit
i want to i want to tell jokes
yeah yeah so what does that have to do
with leno how did leno
come into the is that are they just two
different things
what do you mean like did leno is he
doing it too so he wanted no
no no no he just i think he just caught
it on youtube i think it was like
recommended or something oh that's
amazing
yeah [ __ ] jay leno it's hilarious
that he's watching
i feel like like we're out of the loop
because our shit's on youtube and right
and not on netflix where it's like
i feel like the stars why would they
even think to look on youtube
i told him on the phone i was like you
know i got brought up on stage this
summer
at like a parking lot gig and they were
like this this next comics got a youtube
special and it got a [ __ ] laugh
yeah it got a laugh and he laughed
really hard at that he thought that was
hilarious i'm like it got a laugh that
people are like
oh clearly that's a joke i'm like no
this is what we have to do now right
right yeah he's he's seen like
look i like jerry i know jerry but i
feel like leno feels easier to hang with
you know jerry i'm still on kind of pins
and needles the whole time but leno i
feel like you could kind of let your
guard down a little bit more
i think part of it is kind of like is
how i look at it now man like my friends
are my friends like you're my friend i
have my friend group
you know and then those guys it's like
it's all house money it's like
whatever it's it's great it's awesome
it's almost like
cool to just say you've talked to them
or met them but like i put no
you know i put no major stakes in the in
the conversations i'm like if it go
unless it goes horribly which would suck
right
of course but you know that's the
healthy way to be because i put way too
much and i'm devastated it's like
almost like a hot lady i'm texting that
i'm in love with you know
so that's way smarter because i put
everything i put all my chips in
and uh it never pays off i just think
like it's great that we have these
stories and we get to tell these stories
and stuff and it's like
you know i these legends like i remember
like
jeff ross were telling me stories about
like buddy hacking i'm like yeah
to me that's [ __ ] cool but it's so
cool but yeah it's another thing leno
said he's like these old school comics
he was talking about how much he hated
like last comic standing because
we have to he's like they're like be
funny in two minutes he's like that's
not comedy right
it's not comedy i'm like oh it's cool do
you guys like that say that but he's
like that's not he's like
he's like i forgot who he brought up but
he said someone who would take like
he's like go up and watch this first
comics it takes like a minute and a half
to get to the first punch but the punch
destroys right that was how comedy was
yeah and now it's like um and i think he
likes punch lines but he's kind of like
the hunger maybe the appetite is is off
i don't know
um interesting interesting yeah you can
tell he loves it i mean
for the people who don't know i'm a big
leno fan and he would go
back in the late 70s when there were a
ton of comedy clubs
he had to get good and had to get reps
so he would go to a bar or strip club
put 50 on the bar and say let me do
a half hour if i bomb keep the money if
it goes well
i keep i get the 50 back so you don't
have to lose any money and they would go
okay and then you know a couple times he
did okay
kept the money a couple times he lost it
it's like a pool shark man
yeah i mean like what a badass move like
i just gotta get up this is one way
he knew he had material i saw him once
go up at the improv and he was funny it
was good material
really yeah it was cool it was like it's
probably like five
four five years ago he went up goes up
in a blazer looks like old school but
like yeah he got him i mean
it's cool to watch a legend just go up
and do his thing i was like yes this is
pretty sweet
he's a pro and he's great on pi he did
rogue and he was great he
did a o a like back in the old days and
he zinged everybody he was running the
tables on these he was like zinged opie
and zinc
gym making fun of jim looks and how
they're
like not real men jim's like oh i can't
change a tire he's like ah jesus christ
yeah i'm eating here
come on it was so funny do you see when
louie was on panel with him and louie
goes out and lena went back
that's a great it was a great exchange
it was a great exchange
it was like two dudes who just are like
just at the top
like just like we're [ __ ] quick we're
good yeah
clearly they liked each other it wasn't
like malicious but it was [ __ ] like
louis came for leno and leno's like yeah
man [ __ ] comedy we get at least we
get good stories and [ __ ] you know
yeah here here you know everybody all
you hear now is
it's being sensor oh what's up
sorry to a new beginning baby yeah
here here
that's a new segment you mentioned uh we
should yeah i think the toast is fun we
could come up with like funny toasts and
[ __ ] well that'll be our next week well
that'll be our our homework we'll come
up with
all right i don't i got one alright i
already texted it to you but i'm
toasting the gamestop guys
good for them those [ __ ] nerds on
reddit who beat the system
here here good for the people that got
in and out early
the rest of you it's a pyramid scheme
it's gonna fall
but to the early people well done
well done well done i mean i think that
rocked the foundation of
finance as we know it yeah we'll see
i don't know we'll see we'll see i don't
know but it's [ __ ] it is hilarious
i'm not gonna act like i didn't see that
and laugh my ass off
ah i love it i love seeing the guys on
like msnbc and the tie
the old guy with the white hair like
this is unbelievable this is un
inappropriate or whatever the [ __ ] and
you're like ah shut up you got billions
gamestop is [ __ ] just a it's a
hilarious one to pick
because it's like it's blockbuster but
for video games basically right
exactly yeah the the real loser are the
game stop employees the fat guy with the
zits who's like
wait i don't get anything i still work a
[ __ ] nine to five [ __ ] job
and like you mean my [ __ ] my hourly
wage didn't include stock in the company
[ __ ] i know exactly he's got to go
back home to his ferret
and uh you know the whole company's
through the roof
man is electronic boutique still around
that was one too they all crumble i feel
like i mean
i feel like everything like that like
this is like
borders think of like anything that you
go to get that's a big yeah like dude
going to barnes and noble feels like
visiting a dying relative
yes you're like this is not going to
last long let's just enjoy the time we
have together
this is so true on its last legs here
barnes and noble's cool too i like the
like the call i love it
vibe yeah i like being able to i miss to
some degree i miss blockbuster like i
missed the experience of going to pick a
movie
yeah same i mean it was a great date
thing you go to blockbuster together you
can comment
on all the cover i worked at blockbuster
for like three years did you really
yeah i was just such a movie douche and
i was obsessed with movies i was in
louisiana with nothing to do so i said
hey let me get a job at blockbuster
horrible job by the way i thought it was
gonna be like movie job but it's just
you just work in a library basically you
know you're just putting [ __ ] back on
the shelf in alphabetical order
and uh everybody everybody's got late
fees and you're like hey yo wizard of oz
from 1949 he's like [ __ ] you i'm like
yeah yo 10 grand the guy's like so it
was mostly that
great but uh but yeah it was
i loved blockbuster that was super cool
and then like remember what was it kim's
video or what was that one
in the village same marks legendary yeah
yeah that [ __ ] was [ __ ] awesome with
the posters and the cds and the movies
they had everything you could add like
[ __ ] asian movies and snuff films and
all this [ __ ]
classic faces so much is gone man so
much yeah
so much of new york is i mean of
everywhere i mean like that's you know
cool indie [ __ ] doesn't last long no
i was you know i'm in omaha so they're
they're 10 years behind out here but
i went to the mall and you're like oh
yeah hollister what the [ __ ] is that and
i'm gonna say hollywood video
oh yeah it's like pacsun and spencers
and
uh the [ __ ] uh what's the one with
the high-tech gadgets
uh though they always got the armchair
with the cushion
and the foot rub oh sharper image
sharper image
that's still here you're like wow it was
like a throwback
damn that's hilarious yeah 10 years
behind
yeah maybe 20.
but it's weird i mean it's sad but it's
true but i like going out that's why
comedy is great because you gotta go see
it
you gotta go i mean you can see our
specials but you know we're doing crowd
work and you're riffing on this and that
and and talking about the town like
entertainment
luckily is pretty much mostly live
it's incredible yeah and like i i hope
that it's
not replaceable because you think about
that but like i remember doing like
those rooftop
shows in the summer in new york thinking
like no one would come out and
yeah yeah and like people came to every
single one because
people want [ __ ] to do and i think
they're hungry for things to do
especially right now with like
dude it's a [ __ ] tough year for
everybody it just really is
of course and i think it's just human
nature like you need to connect you need
to interact you need to see things and
like that's why i hate those boxes of
food you know what is that like fresh
you know those boxes like pre-made food
that you you it comes with no i think
you're gonna say fresh direct don't
knock [ __ ]
that's like that's that's legit i know
you're talking about that like the
pre-made [ __ ] we were like what are we
doing here yeah it's like hey
we're gonna send you a box of chicken
cacciatore and it's like little
individual
uh you know like sealed bags of uh
parmesan
and then a little red roasted red pepper
and you're like what are we doing here
like let's go to the [ __ ] grocery
store and see the produce smell it
feel it get the chicken pick it up go
get the salt the pepper whatever it is
i think that's just better for your
brain i agree man
as we're [ __ ] killing our brain with
alcohol but uh
this is what's good for you but but
that's like why i feel like i'm not
gonna stop drinking so i do need
other [ __ ] like you need a break from
other things like that's why like
shower's like one of the last places you
have
right that's right cooking's still
important you like you chopping garlic
you can't look at your phone aha right
so
you listen to a podcast or something i
guess but like it is valuable to have
that time
you're holding [ __ ] in all day you're
internalizing stuff and then you go and
you do your thing and you're like oh the
[ __ ] starts flooding out right premises
start flooding out
yes so true i i live in the west village
and there's a little wine shop by my
house
and they do a thing where you tell them
your last name and you have an account
with them
and it's so stupid you get like two
bucks off every eight hundred dollars
you spend or whatever it is but
it's cool i see this big greek guy he's
got hairy forearms he's got a bad accent
and he's like this is a good white for
this and that's a good red if you're
cooking with pasta i'm like
i get to interact with the guy and i'm
learning about a wine and you see all
the wines you look at the labels i mean
it's just
it's better than just clicking something
and waiting for it
yeah there's something about an
interaction that's like that is nice you
talk you're like you're talking to a
stranger like we've talked about this
before but like
forcing yourself to have to interact
with a human
isn't it like it's an important part of
life that
i guess the next generation will know
less and less about
that's true it's sad but true louis used
to have this great point
i don't know if it was a bit but he used
to talk about how you go to a bookstore
and you could sometimes get laid
like you go to a bookstore you see a
lady talking or reading kind of like
leafing through you know tolstoy and
you're like
oh you got to read this one and she's
like oh really you like that he's like
we should go get a glass of wine and
talk and then
boom you know so like or how about
blockbuster with the uh
with the uh jeff's picks remember that
like you gotta check out jeff's picks
and you're like boy jeff loves
uh carrie elways or whatever the [ __ ]
you know
the idea that you're using toll tolstoy
to get [ __ ] [ __ ]
is so funny to me
by the way some people tweeted me that
my bit from last week louie had a
similar bit it's dumb it's dropped i
appreciate you guys
oh yeah it [ __ ] happens it happens in
millions yeah
that's why you ask that's why i ask but
uh yeah it happens all the time
oh man louie is [ __ ] he's got so many we
were like god damn it
i mean that even that premise is
hilarious just getting laid in the
bookstore is so funny
yeah yeah yeah there's something how
about any
any pet peeves oh you never wrecked
did you give me a wreck yeah yeah devil
in the blue dress oh yeah that's right
that's right walter mosley incredible
just like a classic i'm going to read
more of his stuff it's like a classic
noir i loved it it was uh
it's just a totally if you're looking
for an escape it's another world
it's fun to just go into another world
yeah totally
all right i love it i remember seeing
the movie like in a hotel room
years ago here's good it's good yeah i
think they changed it to make it
southern because i remember a lot of
moments where denzel would have like the
sweat stains on his button down and then
he was [ __ ] one of the ladies and
she was like oh lord it be you know
you're ringing my bell that's what you
kept saying and it felt very southern so
maybe they
finished themselves yesterday oh the
best
yeah uh his new movie looks pretty rough
though
oh what is that i don't know it's like a
cop movie it doesn't look good i think
it's on netflix he's getting a little
typecasted if you ask me
yeah i think you're in so many [ __ ]
hits it's like
tortured tough guy cop uh serious
angry kind of thing do you like training
day
i i lo i own it i love that movie it's
good
but i feel like that was like the
beginning of like every character had to
be like
my man yeah that type of dude we were
like all right
he's incredible i'm a [ __ ] big fan
obviously incredible what's his best
movie do you think
didn't know you like to get wet though
pcp primo
um uh let's see
oh man malcolm x is fun and uh i forgot
that's like a three and a half hour
movie or something it's crazy
spike lee yeah he's a dude orlando
shouts out to that great
underrated character actor love that guy
great and get shorty
oh get shorty [ __ ] rules great movie
and what a cat like
a young gandolfini's in that and uh
dennis farina is that his name
is he i just recommended someone
midnight ron where farina just
like oh that guy's a beast that guy's
great and everything's great and
snatched
hey man yeah the [ __ ] legend ex-cop
in chicago
yeah yeah yeah dude he's a bad
[ __ ] i love farina
i'd get shorty one of my favorite lines
is uh
[ __ ] r.i.p gandolfini too the great
oh [ __ ]
when he goes up to travolta and
intervals this guy's
stuntman and goes yeah he grabs him by
the nuts and like throws him down to
flight of stairs because
he's good
[Laughter]
wow that was movie rules that was back
before travolta
had the uh the massage table incidents
and you still
believe the fact that he uh could throw
a guy down some stairs
although the nutcracker has anyone had a
weirder career than travolta like the
ups and downs
and just like so crazy i mean started
out
bangers it was like uh saturday night
fever and grease and all these huge hits
and then look who's talking then he went
to hell then pulp fiction
then michael i mean it was just like
this phenomenon michael
michael is such trash i saw you tweet
about it didn't you
it's so bad i watched a little bit of it
because i was just like i just want to
remember how bad this is and like i love
andy mcdowell but like god it's a
[ __ ] turd now holy [ __ ] is it bad
they were just trying to ride his
charisma all the way to the bank and
it's like look he's likable but no one's
pulling this [ __ ] off dude
no one's pulling off the angel who's
like just got a horseshoe dialogue
oh yeah there was a couple it was trying
to be like kind of a ghost thing where
they had like the sappy music and they
would
like slow dance alone and she would
shave this ghost is way better than this
is great ghost is great but whoopi
goldberg was [ __ ] funny and ghost
i think she won an oscar for that she
was good
comic started as a comic yeah whoopi's
whoopi was funny
yeah she was funny the the view is a
bummer but she was funny
there's just no way you're making that
show that show's just not gonna be good
no no no a bunch of coos is sitting
around a semicircle
talking about the [ __ ] the the
[ __ ] of the day it's like all right
all right
oohs is such a good insight you [ __ ]
coos whatever i love
it's it's this the polite way to say
[ __ ] basically
or not polite but tv clean
all right pet peeve here we go let's go
i'm howling over here
uh pet peeve i did a guy i did a podcast
with a guy
and nice guy but he said can you meet me
in the park at noon i said yeah you got
it you want to do it
face to face with some zombies nice guy
you're the nice guy
well yeah he was he was very convincing
but so i'm a guy you say noon i'll be
there at noon
it's 11 52. i'm walking there and he
goes
hey where are you at and i go i'm
heading over there and he goes uh
oh all right i thought you were late
like i got eight minutes
and he's like okay just just i thought
you were gonna be late and i'm like
you said dude you called me 11 52. i was
so pissed i don't know why that pissed
me off like you're yelling at me and i
haven't done anything wrong yet
some little dick [ __ ] some insecurity
right there that's some
he what he's basically doing is being
like i'm i'm
nervous you're gonna blow me off and i'm
right on you
before you even get there yes yes
exactly and it really rubbed me the
wrong way i had i called him out when i
saw him
i got there like 11 56 but uh
yeah i'm like i'm still early you should
have looked him dead in the eye and
another lap
to me a minute is a minute like if you
say noon i'll be there at noon but i
don't want to get there
at 11 50. i'm very punctual too i
i if i'm gonna be late i was i was like
four minutes late to a zoom the other
day
and i gave a huge apology i said i i
thought this was an hour later i'm very
sorry and it was four minutes
but it was yeah so you should be on time
to resume but i i'm
i'm i try to be punctual yes you're
[ __ ] with another person's time and i
think it's very rude to be late and
there's some people
who just live to be late oh yeah that's
a
that will [ __ ] you in life being early
or on time is
is uh that's you get a huge leg up if
you're on time
the late guys you just don't trust them
there's
all these hollywood stories about people
who just showed up they would show up
like 30 minutes or later meetings and
just
make sure to like walk watch them walk
in it was like a power move like they're
already there just sitting there you
know
yeah yeah i was at i had a pitch with
netflix this is
64 years ago and i show up and i was
kind of running cause i didn't want to
be late and i was a little sweaty
and i show up and in the lobby in a
t-shirt
basketball shorts and flip-flops was
adam sandler
oh my god this [ __ ] is 20
minutes early
looking at his phone [ __ ] around
scratching his balls and i'm
i'm like barely making it so i was like
i got to get my [ __ ] together and that's
why he's where he's at and i'm where i'm
at
and you know other factors but yeah he's
the coolest
coolest guy worst dresser on the planet
that adds to it the fact that he's
rolling into [ __ ] netflix meetings
and
basketball shorts and and slippers is
[ __ ] legendary
i know with socks by the way like mike
may my gal she's always like that's so
hot that he dresses like that i'm like
that's hot she's like yeah
that's what's so complex about women is
she's like they look beyond
the thing like i see a schlub and she
sees a guy who don't give a [ __ ]
well here's what it is if you're
successful and you dress like [ __ ]
women are like he doesn't care if you're
a bum and he dressed like [ __ ] they're
like you're a [ __ ] loser
that's a great point well it's all about
it's all about
who you are like she gets hot because
he's hot
it's like when women are like i like a
guy who's a dick it's like no you like
a [ __ ] successful dick you don't like
a dick cashier at walgreens that's
so true you like a dick [ __ ] guy in a
suit
who's drinking a martini at the bar and
pulls in 12 mil a year that's who you
like
exactly yeah you it's like the creepy
guy at the office
also happens to be ugly you know
you know the guy giving you the weird
massage you're like oh uh
greg looks like you know he's bald and
all this and fat and
old but if if zach with the [ __ ] gel
in his hair and the
armani suit give you a massage you're
like i'm in
if if joe biden sniffs your hair he's a
creep if tom hardy sniffs your hair
you're wet all right yeah
right here here if tom already said my
hair i'd be wet i mean he's
he's a talent he's great have you ever
seen that movie lock
lock no dude all right highly recommend
it it's like a 90 minute movie
it's the entire movie takes place of
just him and his car
every other character it's insane like i
love movies that are like
we're gonna do it this way i know it
sounds insane
they pulled off dude it's like it's
literally tom hardy just taking phone
calls the entire movie
but it unravels his [ __ ] up plot
uh-huh
and he's dude he is so good i love that
guy well he's such a great actor that
he's enough to carry it you know like
phone booth
with colin farrell didn't really have
the same uh
cachet he was in a lot of stinkers and
then he and then he won me over
big with him bruges and bruges is so
good
no one talks about that movie that movie
is amazing masterpiece
matt and weird and quirky and funny but
dark and a little different i mean
that was a really who who's that
director he's done a few good macdonald
genius [ __ ] genius player genius
he wrote this play called the [ __ ] of
an ishman i'm probably butchering the
pronunciation of that city but like
it's the funniest thing you'll ever read
it's like the dark
he's written he wrote like his classic
is like pillow man that's like the
famous
yeah he all these great plays but like
his big movie was
seven psychopaths was the next one it
was good it wasn't as good
then he did the one with francis
mcdormand that was like super divisive
and polarizing it got oscar nominations
three billboards three billboards yeah i
liked it people hated it
uh but i thought it was cool
i mean i love the cast i i i think
the first one's the best uh in bruges
yeah yeah the cast is great rockwell i
love
and france mcdormand's a great actor but
yeah i felt like that one was a little
forced at some points but uh i thought
it was good
dude his brother did a movie called uh
the guard have you ever heard of that
no it's brendan kleeson and don cheadle
it's
incredible it's really a lot it's like
in bruges vibes it's really [ __ ]
funny and it's really
i mean brendan gleason is like the
coolest he's just like
i don't know that guy he's in in bruges
he's the fat guy he's there oh
he's the main guy yeah he's great he's
great he's incredibly actor now too but
uh
you know dom hall gleason isn't
everything he was in brooklyn he was in
um
star wars that's right you know
literally every movie
is he british or irish irish yeah irish
he's like an irish donald logue
remember donald logan he's great actor
great actor
you don't hear about him look him up
give him a goog if you don't know him
he was in every tv show every commercial
the towel of steve no oh it was like
that was like his breakout movie it was
like a he was like a fat ladies man
it was like it was funny oh wow all
right
he was he's a great actor that guy great
actor funny
great comedic actor really good
see we we know about all these guys that
don't get any love and we respect
quality i think they i think they've had
good careers though i think like they
made money and i think they like
i think like to be a working actor is so
hard and right odds and i think like
i think he is a probably still working i
would think he's so good
yeah i'd hope and then you always forget
about this broadway there's off broadway
there's all this like summer stock
and shakespeare that we we forget about
but that's quality work
for an actor true yeah no he was [ __ ] he
he's great i everything is in his i
think it was on gotham i think he was
like a
recurring on that which was like a big
show so i think i think he did well
all right yeah i hope that i hope he is
because he's a he's a talent
yeah i'll give you my pet peeve oh yeah
i did i did a podcast and a woman called
me
uh she's like comics you guys are the
bravest i [ __ ] i'm so sick of people
calling comedians brave we're not brave
enough of this [ __ ] two things i hate
when they describe comedians brave
and truth-tellers two of the things that
bug me the most
brave navy seals are brave right right
right we're [ __ ] we're telling jokes
if it goes badly
i'd i have my legs you know what i mean
like let's be real
and as for and that's uh truth tellers
we're joke tellers we're truth explorers
truth telling is it sounds so
pretentious yeah if you're only seeking
the truth you're not seeking a joke
yeah i completely agree they always said
about prior he was so honest i'm like
well anybody can be honest
i'm honest but it has to be funny you
know like i can go back i used to wet
the bed
i think that lady's ugly you know
whatever it's easy to be honest
you got to make it funny exactly so that
bummed me that annoyed me
and uh that's fine it just
i mean like i'm flattered that people
think what we do is brave but it's like
yeah it's like we could
we all think different things are brave
but like let's let's not lose the fact
like we're having fun
it's a pretty it's not the idea when
people like it's so
courageous it's like come on we're
[ __ ] we're telling jokes
we're having drinks we're having a good
time this isn't right
right i got a budweiser up there you
know how brave am i but
i will say there are parts of comedy and
it's the part that nobody thinks about
everybody's like
you're telling the truth you're a true
teller you're brave whatever that's not
it the hard part is when you're sitting
in the green room going
i'm hungover i'm depressed i got anxiety
and i got to go be funny for an hour
and kill that's the hard part when
you're like i was on a
[ __ ] six-hour flight i had a layover
i'm hungover
i want to kill myself i'm on two hours
of sleep now i gotta go kill for two
shows an hour each
well said yeah i think it's the idea
that like finding a partner who's down
with this lifestyle is so challenging oh
that's two
finding someone who is who's like okay
with it like they don't get what it is
on paper like
i've said this a lot but like dinner is
a sign of stability to about
we don't give them dinner we give them a
lot of breakfast and lunch
but they're not going to be dinner a lot
i mean sometimes but
like you know so that's one thing the
other thing is just
you know you you nailed it as well with
having to subdue that
that anxiety and having to internalize a
lot of that
uh that pain where i remember one time
with the seller
este the the booker the seller who i
missed
uh and uh i remember
i was going through a breakup but you
could just see i was not well and
yeah host runs up i think with wilson
vince runs up and was like sam you're on
and essie just looks at me and gives me
one of these
[Laughter]
it made me laugh i laughed really hard
like yeah that [ __ ] well that [ __ ] will
help when someone gives you a
[ __ ] bump you know i'm like all right
doesn't work the other way when a guy
says hey how about a smile honey
but if a lady does it all right but no
it's funny
it's funny telling me to turn it on was
pretty funny though i'm like dude yeah
exactly estee's lived
a much harder life than we have yeah
oh no doubt about it in the israeli
uh military you know that life
she's a tough she's a tough broad tough
broad and a nice lady and giving and
she's done so much for all of us yeah
yeah yeah so
yeah yeah you gotta give it up miss all
the seller people miss the comedy seller
more than
anything holy [ __ ] in the words of gary
goldman it's such as a comedy club it's
a lifestyle you go there to eat you go
to the right you go to see your friends
you go there to work out you go there to
hang i mean it's thanksgiving
christmas parties uh all that [ __ ] it's
just you know i
texted liz you had a podcast with the
[ __ ] manager of the place
yeah yeah same vegas good people
all that yes good people
good club yeah uh [ __ ] you had you said
something it made me
go off on a thing in my head and now i
lost it uh
going up when you don't want to go up oh
yeah that's the thing
it's tough because i think the most
exhausting thing and maybe it's
because we're a bunch of introvert
dweebs but the most exhausting thing to
me
is being on when you're not feeling it
like that's why day jobs are so taxing
because you got to go hey rick good cold
out
how the kids doing uh is it only tuesday
another day another dollar
and like you want to shoot yourself in
the mouth because it's so phony and it's
so much work to be that phony where you
want to just go i hate it here i [ __ ]
hate the fluorescent lights and the bad
coffee and the
the clock ticking and all that but like
that's the hard part and that's why
doing those shows when you're when
you're on empty
and you got to be on and funny and
quick that's a good point yeah it's
i mean as i just mocked that this is
like not just truth telling but like
there is an honesty
in our field like when you work at a bar
you're drinking there's like this kind
of right reality that we've all kind of
agreed upon we're like yeah we're not
gonna [ __ ] each other that you
the same way you would in an office and
that and that when
you do tell each other [ __ ] that you
probably wouldn't tell in an office
right where you're like
yeah i had this bad breakup or something
people know [ __ ] is
is going on where they might know
otherwise and
a bar setting makes it all kind of like
less weird also the fact that we work at
night
i think something about like night is
almost like it brings more of a reality
to it
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's kind of like
you're kind of like who gives a [ __ ]
right it's kind of like it's over right
yeah yeah in the morning it's weird to
be
real in the morning right yes yes
completely but at night you're kind of
like yeah it's the end
it's like let's that's the end that's a
funny way to put it
yeah so yeah
there so it it's weird to be phony so i
i think these people know more about us
than they would
like right otherwise like our co-workers
it's beyond co-workers friends like we
will have a drink if you had a drink
at an office you'd be closer with your
co-workers you just
[ __ ] love that guy we'll have a drink
like if you were getting [ __ ] up with
your
with your boys at like home depot on the
hours yes
that's my [ __ ] dude right there
exactly and look truth tellers is
pretentious but
we do get to be honest on stage and it's
it's just such a better way to be than
the whole how was your weekend
another day another dollar like if you
go to uh
[ __ ] youngstown ohio you can go on
stage go well this town sucks and it
gets a laugh
because it's like yeah it does and
you're some outsider from new york
saying that
so like that's nice you don't have to
sit there and go how you guys doing
you're feeling good like
that that would that'd be a bad comic i
forget where trump was in pennsylvania
but his opener was like look i would
never be here otherwise and i got a huge
laugh and i was like that's what we do
that's why he's bad for comedy because
he's taking over exactly
exactly i feel the same way yeah
everybody's like he's gonna be great
he's horrible for comedy
biden's good for comedy but yeah cause
we get back to escapist [ __ ]
uh yeah you know uh
yeah you make a good point i do [ __ ]
miss all my jobs are labor labor jobs
because you can turn the brain
off i'd rather move around move muscles
than
be phony that to me is more like a
couple of those guys it's mostly office
type [ __ ]
look at these [ __ ] hands dude come on
[Laughter]
construction gopher janitor furniture
mover
everyone shocked me because you did that
one for a little while that was your
last one though right
that was about three years yeah but you
know mopping
uh cleaning cleaning bathrooms was a
nightmare i mean
somebody would always blow it up with
diarrhea somehow on the [ __ ] walls
and you had to clean that up but
it was still better than uh
friday finally or whatever the [ __ ] you
say right right
what uh what was that bit again you had
that great bit about it
oh yeah i was mopping the floor it was
like a big deal they told you to mop
early so the place looked good but
everybody showed up early
so i'm trying to mop while there's like
guys and business dudes going in and out
like
grand central station just in and out in
and out so guys be like whoa
and like slip all the time and i was
like [ __ ] sorry they tell me to mop now
and i'm mopping one day and inevitably
one guy just slipped hard
and he goes jesus if the floor is wet
you got to put a sign down
and i'm like i'm mopping in front of you
i am the sign
you know like you know the little guy on
the side doing that that's me but in 3d
that was the big bit
that was [ __ ] funny but did that on
my first tv set so
that was a big one yes that's right
that was [ __ ] comedy central back in
the day yeah when it when it mattered it
was me
che lawrence saint germain emily heller
uh shang wang great good
wyatt's great group yeah
marin was the headliner damn yeah that
was cool that was that was
shay was trembling it was so cool to see
che
then because he was brand new we were a
couple years in we had some
some like some [ __ ] under our belt but
che was like a year in or two years in
and he just got picked because he was so
charming or whatever
and he [ __ ] murdered yeah he was i
mean he was good out of the gate
he was he was uh he was a phenom uh but
he had to have a beer backstage
because he was like shaking damn do you
ever do that
you do that a lot no i never do that
never drink before uh taping no i did it
in the beginning like in the old days
like open mic days in new orleans i was
trembling i was so nervous but i i got
really drunk one day and i said i'll
never do it again
on the taping no i just in general i
don't i try not to drink before a show
not even one i'll have one maybe as i'm
walking on or on stage but
i won't like pound a few in the green
room or anything yeah i'm the same way
i'll do like maybe one but yeah i'm with
you
um interesting do you do it on a taping
i have um i remember like i did a conan
i think it was my second conan and
yeah i i had a couple whiskies in the
green room what
and it was probably my best set ever
[Laughter]
there you go it was like a one was like
wow that was really good
i was so loose and confident um was it
i need a few whiskeys or was just there
and you had one
uh it was just they i said oh it's like
a whiskey and they said oh we'll get
that for you and they did and i
had i had one i was like i'm gonna have
another and then i just felt loose
and that was like back in the days when
i really like ran late night steps in
the ground i mean we got to a point we
got too busy to do that right you know
right
well like i'd run it but i have a chance
to run it like i mean i used to it used
to be everything to us
oh yeah oh yeah it's funny how these
late night sets the views are just
[ __ ] [ __ ] now
i was just talking about this with
somebody it's these these
credits at a comedy special or a comedy
show are like
so in limbo
because like a late night sounds good
but it's meaningless
you know it's almost like a resume thing
more than it is an exposure thing
you know but like uh you can go viral
on a [ __ ] tick tock and that way more
people see
it isn't that funny but yeah it's not
impressive but yeah the tonight show is
kind of impressive is it some clout to
it i guess because you have to get
picked
maybe that's what it is i guess yeah
you're right i mean
also really bad [ __ ] will go viral you
have to remember that yeah
like you'll look at something and you're
like three million views this is so
unfunny
i know i know so i guess that's part of
it but you're right
it's not like it's not like doing the
tonight show with carson anymore i mean
no no one rogan or one viral video all
that [ __ ] is uh way more helpful
your last found was [ __ ] great though
really i i felt like that was one of my
weaker
are you talking about the boat or before
that oh i love the boat oh all right
thanks i
it was so weird and unique i love weird
kind of different [ __ ] sorry for the
rapper though i'm pouring myself another
drankie
ooh is that brand new yeah this is our
friend jamie she came to my my gig the
other night
and uh scott and chelsea yeah a little
manhattan action i'm mixing it on air no
ice in this one though
oh that's yeah jamie lynn shout out that
that's the she gave me a bourbon and you
were scott she's uh
she's like our sponsor i'm loving it
miss
this is nice stuff it's funny how a
dream show
hell that's a good name i love it it
sounds like a british butler
album chop chop
what uh give me uh any good news stories
uh i don't know about good but uh
it did pretty well on twitter what do
you got um
so uh i got a couple
zingers about the first of all
well i'll save that one that one's not
ready yet really but uh
they're doing anal swabs in china
and so uh my three jokes that are
working on stage were
anal swabs in china luckily i hear uh
their swabs are smaller also uh swabs
are uh
i feel like uh corona tests are starting
to they're starting to sound like a
bored husband like
i'm done with this we need more holes
you know
and then uh the last one is [ __ ]
oh damn it i lost it i had a i had three
zingers on the anal swabs oh i was
look i'll take a nose swab i'll take an
anal swab but jesus just do the nose
first
all right all right that was it
i uh that's funny that's good
oh i should also shout out man our
[ __ ] our email keep email we're
getting all these great yes
uh and our email is still one more drink
with mark and sam at gmail
one more drink with mark and sam at
gmail we could change it but
we already got a bunch of emails i feel
like you guys figured it out we're good
yeah
that's better than the old one too it's
nice and short compared to
one more drink or we might be drunk or
whatever it was
with mark and say wait this is the same
one yeah no it's one more drink with
mark and zayn do you want to change it
wow i feel like we gotta at some point
well we have something
we will change that way yeah okay okay i
do like that people are sending us
emails
and they're uh like the people that send
in the subject heading pet peeve
recommendation yes i like that keep
doing that for you guys doing that i
love that what we know we're opening
that's kind of cool and
uh you know the animations and shits yes
the photoshops are incredible we loved
all of them they're so
all that and we'll eventually post all
that so whatever you if it's quality
we'll post it we don't give a [ __ ]
yeah and uh can i read one let's read
one just to encourage you hit me
and then i gotta hear your new story i
don't think i have one actually i
[ __ ] forgot one let me see
okay i don't think i have one i got a
bet i'll do a bit
all right let's see angie g
from angie g hello gents i had one pet
pee
for a few years now and i hope that
you'll agree when people rapidly
self-announce themselves
as empaths what does that mean
like they have a lot of empathy okay i
think
i've mispronounced it empaths empaths
empaths sorry
i think it's a huge sign that you're
talking to a douchebag
if you're intuitive and combat i think
if you were
if you were intuitive and compassion to
the compassion
compassionate i think she might say to
the people around you people would
discover
that by being around you by being around
yourself you don't need to announce it
comically the people that say that about
themselves are the most oblivious and
self-centered ones much love andy g from
nyc
she wrote wow how redundant i meant
announce
themselves oh there we go i completely
agree angie
i agree yeah it's like it's like people
who are like i'm my own worst critic and
we're like are you
giving them it's it's annoying yeah
cause i hate you way more i bet
you know but it's like completely agree
yeah
people that are like i'm very empathetic
i remember i went on a date with a girl
once and she was like non-stop like
she's like i [ __ ]
i gotta go to she's like i'm gonna go to
africa i'm gonna like really i want to
see human suffering i was like you
should look at my face
exactly yeah yeah just do it
enough with the talk if the talk is over
compensation
because you know you don't do it that's
my theory
why do you think people do that they
[ __ ] they're just like i need
to like announce that i'm a great person
yeah
yeah they just want you to think they
are because i i think
they know they're not so they can maybe
convince you that they are
it's like the guy who's like gay guys
are gross they're going to hell and
you're like i think you're blowing dudes
you know why there's why is there so
much energy behind that
it's cause there's something internal
with you yeah i think you're right
yeah that's what it is it's like it's a
weird thing we're like
i don't even know if they always know
though i think they're correct i think
sometimes they're just like no i'm like
a healer i think being a healer is like
something people are very i'm like i
know i'm like
i get i feel pain in other ways and it's
like well you don't feel my pain and
you're talking to me
i don't know if you know if you're
feeling that much pain but exactly it's
it's like that old uh
joke from the show seinfeld where george
is at the diner with jerry's like
yeah you know one of my talents is i can
sense the slightest human suffering and
jerry goes
anything right now [ __ ] perfect
perfect perfect so true yeah but
just don't announce just do enough with
the and the out sing just go
my brother went to the peace corps in
africa for two weeks two years
helping uh like african people in a
village learn french
and math and all these things never
brought it up never talks about it never
posted about it just did it yeah
i think that's how you do it although
that's not the way anymore i mean think
no the amount of posting people do the
amount of like
it's just posting and boasting man like
look what i [ __ ] did
and it's all about like i'm uh i'm a
great person
that's what it really comes down to is
like it is social media
has the addiction to likes has really
brought out the worst in us which we've
talked about a million times but like
it's brought out to the point where
you're like this is a brag sheet
yes yes exactly and and
i we don't even know if you did do this
or you actually do feel that way this is
just what you're putting out this is how
you want to be perceived
i don't even know if you're i mean it's
the old uh it's the old adage
i don't even know if it is old but i
might have made it up it's like if
if you do a good deed and don't post
about it did it happen
you know yeah that's true i don't know
it was like there's like that woman um
there's that [ __ ] viral video that
woman that really hot white chick who
just gets out of a car
takes at the black lives matter thing
and it just gets right back in the car
yeah with the drill on the on the
plywood like that's the most
telling 2020 uh like
this is who we are as a person summed up
in one
piece of [ __ ] video i could tell it was
extra bad because i am a great empath
so yeah there you go
that's so true yeah it's like the model
there was that model in manhattan who
went around with a blm
it's like onesie on and she looks super
hot and like all these black were like
[ __ ] you you're not you're not helping
get out of here
it was great it's so
uh that person just gets
yes anded every day i know exactly
you're
modeling all day like you're the [ __ ]
you're great yeah
yeah it's like it's it is funny like
with the big groupie like
no boo that's the only time you can get
like that
uh because one-on-one no one's gonna
[ __ ] tell that i mean maybe a couple
of people but like
you know yeah chelsea handler do a do a
documentary about white privilege great
idea that'll
click people will enjoy that meanwhile
all right
specials to netflix and they're just
like here let me just pour some [ __ ]
diarrhea on your [ __ ] tape right
there let me just
dump some diarrhea on your spot exactly
that's good stuff oh yeah you got a bit
let's try a bit
um [ __ ] should i try one that i'm like i
can't crack
one of them i can't crack and one of
them i'm like i just came up with which
one should i try
hey i'm down here both uh all right i'm
down
all right all right let me try the first
one i just
came up with it's like um
so this woman heckled me the entire set
you know obvi drunk annoying heckled me
the entire show and
of course afterwards slid into my dms
and uh that's great already do not have
sex with her
she doesn't deserve it and i was like oh
yeah i like that you're
assuming that sex with me is a reward
right right you think like i've never
pulled my pants down and been like it's
your lucky day
[Laughter]
feel free to collect you know right
right that's part of it's like and i was
thinking like there's more that that's
like something there and i think there's
something more about like the idea of
like
i get like uh with a joke or
[ __ ] afterwards i get the same sound
i get a wonk wonk
that's like maybe a tag but the first
part is like i think there's there's
some meat in the idea
definitely yeah this is not this is not
a reward for like this is not good for
her
yeah i like going the other way
punishment that's what i was gonna say
this is more of a punishment than a
reward so like
i will [ __ ] her because she heckled me
the whole set that's how i'll get back
at her by [ __ ] her
and you know not getting her off or
whatever it is not satisfying her
although i don't want to give her two
bad performances in one night
well if she stops interrupting it could
be good
that's the other thing it's like you
were bad at my best
you think she's gonna be well behaved
while i'm [ __ ] her ah
right she's gonna be on top of you like
you suck you know you're
you're not good at this i'm bored i'm
like can someone throw her out i'm like
[ __ ] it's just me
all right right right
no that's great and also there's
something to the fact that she's
heckling you
and then wanting to [ __ ] you so you're
like
like uh missing it weird yeah well what
the hell you were mean to me you were
rude to me you ruined my
show and then you're like it was only
because i liked you
you know it's like it's like a kid at a
schoolyard punching a girl on the
shoulder and
the girl's like what are you doing
they're like he likes you that's what
women do they nag i mean young people
yes
yeah women will neg you now i i had a
bit about it in one of my specials like
like it was gonna be hard to top because
it was like [ __ ] boom boom boom but
like there was something about
for me at least but like there was
something about uh there's something
about like
nagging i remember talking to this girl
and she was like i feel like i'm funnier
than you and i was like oh okay
like i'm just like all right whatever
she's like because i feel like i'm like
like i feel like i'm funny i was like
okay do you and she was like yeah so far
i think i am and i'm just like
what do you think do you think i'm just
like this isn't last comic i'm like how
do i wow her in two minutes
you know yeah what do you think this is
right
how unbearable would i be if i was just
like i'm on
good point and also i don't know if you
feel this way but when a woman is
nagging me i'm like
this is a dumb dude move you you should
be better than this
you've seen idiots hit on you your whole
life and you're gonna pull the same
horseshit
like you should know better you're a
lady you're a woman you you guys are
smarter and you guys are
or whatever you want to call it like
you've been hit on more so you should
know the bad moves and now you're doing
the bad moves
it sucks you're totally right i mean
it's yeah it's one of those things where
it's like
well they're just [ __ ] on you and
they're just like oh uh like what are
you thinking i'm like
were you thinking of a joke i'm like no
i'm thinking of like a polite way to say
yes
that your opinion is not important to me
and i don't
care if i see you again yeah that's what
i'm i'm trying to find a nice way to say
i don't care for you i don't know i get
what do you say
uh yeah it's a tough spot and
yeah it's hard as a comic in that way
because like look we're flattered this
girl's trying to talk to us it's cool
we'd like to talk to a lady but when
you're kind of being like why aren't you
funny now and be funny and you're you're
you suck
i'm funnier than you you're like i don't
know what to do here should i just
insult you
but that's going to ruin it it's it's a
weird spot i want to be nice but you're
also annoying
it's also the second we get off stage
and it's like why don't you do your job
the second you finish your job
yeah right right yeah exactly i don't
think any other job has that
yeah it's one of the things where i'm
like i'm
talking to you i'm being polite i don't
know what yeah i don't know what to do
here yeah it's been 11
seconds what do you want from me another
another act
like should i juggle come on
we're talking here so we're humans also
like you've seen our acts we're not like
[ __ ] we're not jim carrey we're not
like
you know we're like [ __ ] kind of like
these are bits we're [ __ ] trying out
observations or thoughts yeah you know
and like you'll make the act you just
won't be around to see it
that's that's good and the the easy joke
is like what are you doing she's like
i'm a data entry and you're like all
right well how about you type some
but you know whatever but like why can't
why can't i just have a moment
i still got to be funny and like also i
am funny but now you're
you're putting me on the spot it's like
saying to a stripper hey i met a
stripper at the mall
after her set then she's not wiggling on
a pole
you know like that actually that i do
take
issue with actually that i find to be no
but uh
yeah no you're right man what do you got
for a bit well no that's
that's really interesting and uh i'm
excited to hear how the date went
but uh now this one is a little spicy
so so hang with me here folks true story
so uh the whole point of the joke is i
hate when you make a joke
about a specific person and they think
you hate
the whole group you know like if you
make an oj joke you're like what are you
racist you're like i'm making fun of a
murderer
you're making this a black thing you
know uh so this
this trans woman came up to me after
show and she's like you suck
you're not funny i hate your act or
whatever she said
and i was like geez so i was like well i
was pissed
so i was like you look like a man and
of course she she flips out and she's
like you're transphobic
i'm like no no i just you hurt my
feelings so i knew that would hurt yours
you know it's nothing to do with with
your group and i was like do you hate
all comedians she was like no just you
and i'm like well that's how i feel and
that
that gets a laugh but it's true it's
like
you're super all i don't hate all trans
because all trans aren't as mean as you
you're [ __ ] mean
how come you can be mean to me but i if
i mean to you
you know yeah i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna
you went straight for the thing you
thought would hurt her the most
yes that's it i don't mean any ill will
towards the group
what was her first line again say it
again like you you you're not good at
comedy you're not funny
something in that world we both went to
the first thing that we thought would
hurt the other person the most
exactly i think that's the angles like
because that's interesting to me where
it's like
you're like will you identify as
i identify the woman like why identify
as a comedian yes
as a funny guy as a funny guy that to me
that's
the the angle is like we both said the
shittiest thing
possible right right because you can
call me ugly or stupid or
gay whatever but comedy i care about
just like you care about
you know transitioning or whatever the
[ __ ] well yeah she said you should say
she's like you say i put a lot of work
in to be a comedian she's like i put a
lot of work into
uh being a woman you go 15 years exactly
ah that's great that's great
i'm using that we use it that's great
yeah
have you been on one of them on tv i
mean i know you're not transphobic so i
think to me it's like funny the idea of
like
going after a particular person yeah
there's more even there is like
that's progress when i can go after a
particular person
yes and mean nothing malicious to a
group
that's progress no i don't care about
the group i'm worried about her
and she's worried about me she doesn't
hate all she likes comedy she just hates
my act
and that's how i feel so yeah you're
right i went for the jugular because she
went for the jugular
yeah so i'm treating her equally and
there's some line to be had about a
jugular
yeah that adam's apple could take a take
a hike too
but yeah so she went from my jugular
vein i looked at her jugular looked a
lot like my jugular
we had the same jugular yeah uh
i meant we were all one person you make
it worse right
but you're right i think it could kind
of because obviously it's a dicey bit
and it's a touchy subject with the whole
trans stuff because i get they go
through a lot of [ __ ] and discrimination
and all that so like
i get that that is i'm walking a
tightrope here but the point is like you
said
it's about the jugular i'm just trying
to hurt you because you hurt me and i'm
treating you
just like a regular old person not like
some weird thing
that sounded bad transmits trans bits
are always tricky like they always
you walk that line of a groan and then
you also walk that line of like did i
get too hard of a laugh
like i think you know what i mean where
you're like oh they're laughing at right
so you're kind of like
is this worth it i think if you make
this enough about you
it's worth it you know right right we're
like
uh i remember right a bit where
something like this woman was like oh
it's tough for like
a woman like me but it was like she was
like a beer and i was like you're a guy
though it was years ago whatever
yeah i wasn't i didn't know as much
about them and she was like
uh excuse i'm a woman i was like oh i
couldn't tell i'm sorry and she was like
yeah well like you [ __ ] and she kind of
got like really pissed at me blah blah
and then i was like all right i can see
that you're a woman now because you're
you're furious at me and i have no idea
why
so i can tell you're a woman you know
yeah that bit would [ __ ]
it would kill or would get uh
interesting you know what i mean i'm
butchering the setup but you get what
i'm going i get it yeah i get it i
i i'm into it but yeah i can see
i feel like times have changed so much
that that that's a different joke now
almost exactly this is years ago i also
had a thing where it was like
i remember i met a woman after a show i
said [ __ ] in a joke it's probably like
six years ago yeah i didn't know it was
a slur this woman came up to me after
show and she's like
that's we have a trans kid it's you know
show is really good she was so cool
about it i was like
she's like yeah it's just you know it's
a sl it's a slur and like
you could probably pull that joke off
without saying that and i was like cool
like that you don't get like feedback
yeah often where they're like yeah hey
just a heads up
show is good this is like here's a
little tidbit and i'm like
perfect yeah and we want to know too
because we don't want to sound like uh
bobby slayton out there you know we
don't want to sound like some [ __ ]
bigot or something we
we'd like to get a laugh and this goal
of like offending people i don't get i
want everybody to have a good time and
get it and whatever but like
so that's a helpful constructive tip one
of my favorite bobby slade moments is
uh he was on i was listening to him on
marin and he told a story about how like
he is like
talked about tell you how he'd do this
bit where like a woman would get up and
go to the bathroom and he would grab the
stool and sniff it
[Laughter]
and marin was like yeah i feel like a
lot of comics have done that and but
bobby goes
yeah but i was the first one to guess
the year like it was a bottle of wine
that's hilarious that's the part he's
proud of
that's great
it's great made me laugh so [ __ ] hard
yes the year i guess the year sniffing
vagina
is like a dying art thing like remember
this the finger sniff
the panty sniff the stool sniff that was
like a big part of comedy and humor
it wasn't a thinking man's gag no no
no definitely not you know mort saul
wasn't doing a simple step
but it did make me laugh i'm not going
to act like that
that gag is not yet i mean this is his
comedy goal i don't care who you are
you know you you see uh charlie kaufman
do that you're laughing
[ __ ] charlie kaufman such a genius oh
genius
genius guy we watched being john
malkovich recently and like
it's just [ __ ] good you know what
he's got he's the best at
you know when you're really high or when
you're like in some kind of zen
meditative state and you're going into
like these crazy
chasms of your brain you're like keep
going keep going he's got that he
he can go into these crazy creative
chasms and then still
write it i go in those guys and i slip
out and i go what the [ __ ]
was that he can he can still hold on to
it i'm with you i think i get scared i
think i get
trapped but yeah yeah there's something
about
how he goes to these like that those
some of those holes like
also the fact that he's just like john
malkovich is just like boys with charlie
sheen in that movie
it's so [ __ ] random and funny like
that movie just rules it's just so
[ __ ] weird
but yeah oh man catherine keener in that
movie
so sexy sexy i know i wonder what that
was because she wasn't that she's not
hot in other things really
she's but she is so kind of she's just
like she's she's a great actress so she
just knows
how to like be whatever she is just
amazing i saw her on a flight once
and i just panicked because i got out of
the bathroom and she was right there and
i go
i love you
[Laughter]
oh my god thank you i was like oh you're
the best sorry it's like
she seems like a real she seems so
she just seemed like a nice person yeah
yeah she seems like a real person
more than like you know you meet uh i
don't know
like uh carmen electra when we mentioned
her like i feel like if you meet her
she's gonna be like oh geez all right
whatever yeah thank you she probably
gets it all day long but keener feels
like a real person yeah i mean carmen
electro anyone who [ __ ] dennis rodman
we're like yeah you probably are not
gonna be as easy to hang with
yeah yeah you got some demons yeah
um park chair part native american by
the way
carmen electra yeah i think i feel like
anytime somebody's ex like really hot
there's like a native american thread in
there
interesting yeah interesting theory
oh they're just so interesting look i've
been doing a deep dive on native
americans on youtube because i watched
that new tom hanks movie
news of the world it's okay it's a
little different than i thought it would
be
i went in thinking this and it was that
but uh it's good it's good it's a
western type
i heard the book is really good i can
see the book being better because it
it's a lot of like
it feels like eight different movies in
one and they had to make it work so
it's heavy but it's it's good [ __ ] tom
hanks rolls man
oh yeah you know what's a i feel like
the last great western i saw was
probably like the true grit remake was
solid i thought that was yeah
i'll tell you 310 to yuma is amazing
never said that
oh dude you would love that the remake
okay and then tombstone is great
tombstone's cool
unforgiving is great unforgiven
yeah so there's a couple great westerns
out there wyatt earp is pretty good
pretty good pretty good but yeah uh
native americans man i think we have a
weird warped
kind of perception of native americans
what do you mean
well first of all everybody's like oh we
we wiped them out
we killed him but it's like yeah that's
true but they also
killed us all the time randomly like
if you lived in texas it was just kind
of normal that like oh
my baby was kidnapped and my wife got
shot through the head with an arrow
you're like all right well we should
move
or we should uh you know like so they
were nuts but they would also kill each
other and that's the other part no one
talks about like
we act like they were these peace loving
pipe smoking
uh you know tp chanting but they would
kill the [ __ ] out of each other too
so like some of them hated some of them
and they would
hang out with us like we got to watch
over those choctaw they're [ __ ] wild
but we'll hang out with you and we we
want you to protect us it's pretty
interesting this podcast took a turn man
wow
beef with them i'm just saying it was it
was a wild time
you know for sure um
we got to do a patreon too should we
should we wrap up yeah oh sorry yeah
we're going long here we're going along
but i mean it's i mean
talking i could talk to you
all right i've been drinking here uh
yeah yeah let's do a patreon
this is a [ __ ] bang well remember to
subscribe on our patreon as well which
is uh
just patreon.com we might be drunk pod
follow our uh new instagram uh at we
might be drunk follow both of us on all
the socials and [ __ ]
uh watch our specials i'm in i'm in
jersey this weekend
stress factory february 4-6 mark what do
you got going on man
i'm doing a soul joel coming up have you
ever been out to royersford pa it's a
it's uh
one of the better outdoor situations
going
uh it's great yeah really fun i got some
good nights coming up in raleigh
uh that's enough funny bone in dayton
so if you're in the syracuse funny bone
oh that's gonna hurt i'll be funny but
i'm doing a whole funny vote right
what's that it's gonna hurt your soul i
know i'm i'm not looking forward to it
so
good people come out we gotta we gotta
drown out the [ __ ] weirdos and
pill heads uh i'm grateful for it and uh
yeah i'm grateful for all the listeners
to this i feel like this is like
new but but people are listening and
people are liking and uh that's that's
great
yeah it's hitting a nerve and there's a
lot of drunks out there and a lot of ex
drunks and we love you all and uh keep
drinking keep listening tell a friend
get on the patreon
and then uh at one more drink with mark
and sam at gmail because uh
and remember to label which one you're
throwing as a wreck a pet peeve a joke
whatever but man i'm loving these so we
really appreciate you
and yeah follow the instagram cool
thank you